on entend souvent dans les médias à tort
il ya vu tant de nouvelles
contaminations en france
hier aujourd'hui donc ce ne sont pas des
nouvelles contaminations ce sont des
gens qui ont réussi à se faire dépister
et qui se trouve être positif pour un
cas dépistés positifs il peut y avoir
dix fois cent fois plus de nouvelles
contaminations
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que bon ben voilà on a connu
ce pic épidémique assez classique dans
une transmission interhumaine aux
alentours du 15 avril puis la
décroissance qu'on connaît on se voit là
on pensait pas que ça allait totalement
disparaître maintenant on à faire un
virus transmission interhumaine un
niveau d'immunité très faible aux
alentours de 10% dans notre pays donc on
n'a pas fini d'en entendre parler
néanmoins on s'attend pas à voir une
deuxième vague de la même ampleur la
première on s'attend plutôt à voir un
niveau dans des mii cité avec des
nouveaux pics qui seront à des
probablement à des niveaux inférieurs à
la première vague donc plusieurs petites
vagues si vous voulez et cela tient au
fait que quand même il ya plus de
mesures barrières dans notre pays que
déjà beaucoup de personnes
malheureusement âge ils en sont décédés
et que petit à petit les immunités roman
[Musique]